[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what will become of my different
[Music]
factions wow the mic is like super loud
I'm sorry
oops turn this down Jesus Christ hello
hello hello hello hello hello hello
hello one sec let's go up the chat hello
I need to get some great like some comfy
ahead friends cuz I lied streamed
earlier and my ears are still hurting
from that bloody livestream could these
bloody headphones but whatever we'll
deal with that we'll work through it
cuz we can't play a plague tale
innocence but before I do I just want to
plug my friend Jenny's channel because
they're playing DD all day for charity
for Mental Health Week which i think is
amazing I got to play my first D&D game
ever this morning this afternoon
twelve o'clock and yeah I'm just very
I'm very thankful for them for letting
me like join because I did not know what
the hell I was doing but I had a lot of
fun and I was a sheep and a hat off to
piss arms and legs so that was fun game
so anyway if you guys want to check out
theirs or even just give a donation for
the mental health charity of their
choosing then you can go check that out
I don't know what I'm starting my
livestream telling you to go somewhere
else but go somewhere else just for a
second check that out give them some
love and then come back here maybe lady
or maybe you could go matter and just
have to live streams of same time say
why
yeah that could be a thing um anyway
yeah don't worry YouTube comments won't
come on twitch and vice versa
if you're on different platforms you
won't be able to see each other just the
way it is but luckily I can see
everyone's comments from both twitch and
YouTube so don't worry anyway hello a
marital oh hey Danny hey card Squire hey
Susan hey it's your boy mantas hey new
system I stumbled my way here I'm sure
what's happening well I'm glad you found
us I hope you're stumbling wasn't due to
you becoming hurt or something in some
way you're just stumbling around maybe
you'll stick around maybe not who knows
hopefully you'll like it anyway I'm not
sure if the audios ok you guys can let
me know I feel like my mic is like way
too high
so I'm gonna turn this down a little bit
okay so you guys have let me know about
the audio I don't want to turn the music
down like too much but obviously you
guys still gonna hear me so just let me
know whether this sounds ok thank
Biser them
thanks for coming just to say hello
anyway
card Squire I'm not sure I've never
played vampire or order 1886 so you tell
me hey Luke ads hey Michael how P bereft
it was good yeah I was good actually
I never usually do anything for my
birthday but all my new workmates for
like let's go out for dinner you can
choose and that chose tide cuz I love me
some spicy food and they surprised me
when I went to the toilet they got me a
bath a glass of champagne which is very
nice by but that up but thank you for
coming maybe I will still be here who
knows
no I went to my drug dealers with a
grilled cheese hopefully score some
snack and you wound up here well I mean
I don't know what to say we're much
healthier for you than smack right maybe
a bit less addicting but you know
hopefully just the sense chaining if not
bars we shall see but you won't have
that come down last good thing you know
anyway no one has complained about the
audio so I'm guessing we're OK
and yeah I'm just gonna start straight
away I guess stop playing this game I'm
really excited
thank you Father follow Michael tan milk
yeah I'm really excited a this game
because I was reading some reviews about
it and a lot of people have related it
to hell-blade hell blade was freaking
great it was so good so yeah very to
come forward to this love single-player
and narrative driven games if you know
me you know I do and you also know that
I love horror games
and this seems like the best of both
worlds so shut up YAG man and play the
game yes okay yes here it is
oh okay oh damn rats
oh damn back oh I'm becoming a rat
I'm just moving some stuff don't forget
you guys are gonna have to let me know
if anything goes funky with the audio
like if you want to hear the game more
or hear me more or hear me less you
gotta let me know okay okay anyway now
that we've got that out the way
yackin why are you in such a good mood
because I'm about to play a new game and
I had a good day
I mean dandy was fun I've always wanted
to play D&D I just never he never did it
and I was so worried about it I was
actually up last night like thinking
about it and I overthought my character
way too much because it was just a
little short D&D campaign and like no
one even got to know my backstory but I
put so much thought I'm sorry anyway it
gets dark really quickly so we bet for
that that's a good thing card Squire I
look forward to that oh this music oh
this string yes let me just quickly on
settings make sure that
we want some subtitles yes please
[Music]
okay concept of you guys
yeah I was super nervous I was super
nervous for dealing
[Music]
no attention okay oh geez my family arms
Wow
this this one looks quite nice and
they'll read like bread yeah they can
perhaps go from red
that's cool
the devran legacy
go and then do I have to do something
you still loading it's okay I met you
whoa pretty that's your only ambition
for me to follow I will beat them and
watch them eat my dust is I forge ahead
hell yeah that's I shall need a good
horse you've been going on about this
walk for ages why here the tree which
tree the apple tree father I want to
take the Knights challenge once more the
Knights challenge but you're not 10
years old anymore
cutie all right let's go look at the
green thief is in a hurry to fight it
out your beast thinks with its stomach
as usual well there's something you both
have in common that's us yeah
let's keep going why did it why did she
go
[Music]
look your mother's ribbon is still here
this is where I caught it her yes Father
I know Oh daddy with us I guess my mom's
like ill okay hello Don Authority room
right as I was saying we all have
obligations I have to manage these lands
your mother has to take care of your
brother
you can hardly ever see you listen we
are here for you now follow me run man
run this is the tutorial where I do all
of the boring stuff this is pretty nice
Thanks this apple tree was planted when
you were born it will prove your worth
tonight what are the terms of the test
the sacred apples of the sacred apple
tree have been corrupted by a great if
who destroys six of these rotten apples
by the time I count to ten
my accepts your challenge I can see some
stones near the trunk over there go and
get them and tell me when you're ready
ready I'll show you I'm not a child
anymore stand behind this truck so here
we go huh oh wait I didn't hold damn it
Oh God come on come on go it was a
present from you oh yes quite forgotten
[Music]
doggy wait where did he go
I guess he went down yeah it looks like
he went down here all right do I need
another Rock OOP good works
yeah
oh I was doing them
leo
appear
[Music]
what are you doing mr. Badal oh okay
never mind I take it back some game
nicely for a little feast that might
work but you'll need to get closer
this grass will keep you hidden if you
stay alone
[Music]
sneaky sneaky
sneaky sneaky
[ __ ] okay you guys know I'm bad at
stealth
[Music]
it gets facing the other way that was
not yeah its facing that way
it's getting too to hike it off don't
look at me piggy those noises
can't see I got him but the feast isn't
on your plate
[Music]
I promise you tonight we shall dine like
kings whoa whoa did you see her
eyelashes is like sweet tonight we shall
battle like kings okay let's go
I mean apart from that looks really good
so far okay let's get back out it's
cooled it I actually was almost allowed
in there that way yes blood is that the
boar you should get up sounds like
things again your mom
crotch
oh yeah
it's Abajo what the hell Liang couldn't
have done that the plane could have done
my either that's way too short
where's the dog
Oh
who did this okay
[Music]
devilry is this
we must go immediately
yeah her eyelashes do not stay in one
place it's kinda creepy
[Music]
I shall organize a hunt to go and find
your mother tell her I must speak with
her she's probably looking after Hugo
yes of course
Amisha chickens he was a good dog
I wonder if that's like something that
I've got step up hmm look my settings
graphics
what's up man
I'd like to say I mcclee what I'm doing
but I don't I don't know I don't know
oh wow it's not a major major thing hey
chickens chickens chickens jakku hey
pigs you big baby
this is cool
farm simulator
grant us health and he plague from our
door
oh the plagues are your thing
take care of you peace deserves his
place at your side that's cute
I like this attention to detail
by Denix know where it's a totally get
if you want to play this on your own
hey your groove
this amazed me I used to UM go and visit
my auntie uncle and they had a farm and
it was always like me and my cousin
would just play with the geese and the
chickens and stuff
[Music]
the keys are two really scary I wouldn't
recommend you chasing them like that
Gabrielle is mother upstairs yes she
spent the night there the little one had
another one of his advice Oh what's
wrong with my brother
did you hear what happened at the
village being bitten kids can you
imagine each time it happens at night
and now vampires vampires you're
freaking me out doc my vampires
interesting you see that this is really
really detailed
[Music]
so you didn't need that ball that bad
this is June yeah you had loads of food
back here
now what's this hmm cinnamon I'd almost
forgotten what it smells like
mmm they were right to hide its father
we put it in every dish but I couldn't
ask for information about this the
cinnamon
okay cool
will ever play in the full game probably
not I've got work in the morning but
this is just my first impression oh you
mean like that you might like tonight um
maybe to put it depends on like how you
guys like it how I like it so stick
around and then you can tell me if you
want to see what but yeah not not
tonight cuz I've got work tomorrow here
we go let's go up to mom thank you know
she can only go into her mum's room
because of father's orders is this my
room that was for my dog Thank You
hand-woven doors are often decorated
with lace and used primarily to protect
tables from hot dishes this dolly is
adorned with family coats of arms a
traditional pattern for a young
well-bred girl swimming for young world
where girls when they learn to crochet
your weddings witness the customs no
cool she is a harp in her bedroom most
people learn guitar she learns the harp
you know empty room spare room probably
oh no it's probably her brother's room
isn't it so let's go to see my mom bye
montage thanks for coming
mother
you know you're not supposed to be here
I know but something attacked Leon in
the forest my dear I really wish I had
the time to listen to your adventures
but
but it's true Leon was lying there on
the ground I mean he was
what why but let's go behind me and do
not open the shutters
whatever happens but Hugo he is not
contagious I realize you hadn't warned
him but he will be alright trust me see
mrs. she hardly knows her brother
when she get close these potions mother
have I'll be able to kill him
oh that's why she said distant she's
just trying to trying to heal Hugo
whatever is wrong with him
[Music]
where is she Hugo
how old is he
it's me your sister a museum
hello you haven't seen each other much
mommy will be back soon
did he talk
No hello Nicolas he killed two of our
men
[Music]
I won't ask again where is your son in
good hands
why do they want the Sun
there's not mommy my god
scheisse go off this way
Oh God come on out the freakin door
where you're [ __ ] doing
why why okay find it this way
[Music]
killing everyone just looking for this
kid what is he like
well she said he's not infected so maybe
he's the secret to the play like the
play cure come
sure sure
what does she go
oh god oh god oh god oh god just keep
going
sigh
go go go go go go I hate that we can't
move any faster than this
oh yeah is the vice the mums and the
research about the voice so he must be a
cure to the plague or something like
maybe he has the plague but he hasn't
gotten any worse and that's because
she's stopped it
where do you think you're going yes mama
to the rescue my children
she can tell me now like why are there
so many people here looking for my
brother what is happening
you will be alright Jimmy come on
Julie take your sister's hand I'll go
first and you just have to follow me
over it
you have to cross the gardens
yes
they are everywhere
where'd she go yeah I've lost her now oh
no not not that Bush only these ones we
are in disappeared says he watched the
kids grow up flowers you can do better
than that take him
oh yeah you first
have a little think come back you don't
die without talking to me first
boy in a bunch of [ __ ] how long can it
take
okay
oh wait but oh okay
cuz I have no rocks
I have a feeling I'm gonna get caught a
lot in this game but why not some I know
tell me now because you're gonna die and
then I still won't know what's your
surroundings and throw metal objects
fine fine fine I see what you're trying
to make me do here I'll do it
mother throwing these spots really
alright
listen I know what you poor people are
like always got a sneaky coin hidden
somewhere
hold oh no I see cuz I guess the pot
will make more noise right I should have
been an executioner but always blends
your work and your in the wall what was
that noise
okay let's go
why is he talking to a deaf person
made it is come on get under the yellow
medic just concentrate on the door
you're a brave boy you prove it to me
every day
quick go through all right
Oh
well I can't even see this is not fun I
mean I mean it is
I'm like no too scary
okay go give up well why don't I help
impress yeah I should do
[Music]
[Music]
migraines given me a time
courage my darling
it's okay
okay
right now I'm gonna help Hugo first
there you know that's very nice he said
thank you you go - I like him they
already have a pot anyway but you
thought it's alright careful and go on
and get the pot did they do diddly doo
doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo doo I
doesn't even need it because I've
already got a pot I just wanted to prove
that I could make it so now I'm just
gonna come back so which way where do I
want him to go I guess I wanted to go up
here though right
maybe what are we give them out there oh
we could go over there there okay well
I'll just Chuck this mother and you can
eat it
I chose the right to call them notes No
they're coming come on come huh oh good
oh good thank you
Dylan nothing
the cotton gate we should be able to get
out of here this is one God left school
I used to practice firing it
boom that's pretty dodgy though cuz
wouldn't he'd look for the source of it
I mean if this was real life I would not
do that because you would definitely
look for the source of the throw and
that would obviously be the shrubs there
you go
now my god
this way follow me don't talk so loudly
this list your card right around the
corner
my darling go and hide quickly now
but you have to take your brother to
Lorentz's the doctor yes help me treat
you
what about you you have to leave me a
Mesa you
why is she not going with them
hi the house she just literally
committing suicide basically why didn't
she just Mun that makes no sense I'm not
the only one slightly annoyed that I
hope that gets explained because that
she she she totally could have gone with
them but what that [ __ ] where am I going
I'm running towards them [ __ ]
don't hurt the child throws speared at
the child speared spear
she's nothing anymore I'm sorry
oh it's not that thing these like lives
on the ground that's killing them all
what is that can't be the rice no it's
gonna be something else
[Music]
don't jump
mm-hmm okay so I'm kind of confused
about why I mom couldn't come with us
because she totally could have come with
us I know there's a weird thing living
underground that's like eating people I
am not really eating them but it's
definitely dragging them under like
maybe it's just a lonely creature um
perhaps it's the hordes of rats
we don't know also our brother is ill
with some sort of migraine but I think
that's why people want him and there's
also some vampires okay
the village must be further on someone
there should be able to focus on the
rentals
you go
Hugo
[Music]
[Music]
mommy won't be happy when she finds out
as I need the water
he he has no clear
okay yeah joy yes
did you know apparently yes of course
we're not gonna get dry in these cells
anyway did you know that when Zalman
yawns and if you yawn like after them
that's because of conscious you care
about them because that's what you did
impacts you would like copy each other
it's just what I heard so if anyone
journe after I just yard thank you for
caring I wouldn't want to go back I mean
this is risky right we don't know if
people are still here or not I'm glad
you're okay packed but good boy
[Music]
which right now is to the actual main
door
oh she got not now but don't touch them
they're all rotten how can you think of
food right now because he doesn't
understand this abeyance at the
situation that you guys are in obviously
excuse me please wait oh this isn't
where they came for my seat hmm scared
of us it's your foot there boy look at
my making me is that and he can't run it
would be a liability then where did he
go Oh
it's anyone there we need help no one is
going to let us in what's the matter
with him hmm well obviously they've been
raided as well I think someone's been
spreading rumors about us and our family
what do you guys think back in the day
you you and you got smacked in the head
with a trowel
Wow
[Music]
but where are they stop running around I
am a strict sister but I guess I I have
to be I'm looking for those people that
were talking this place is really
amazing I just need some help
[Music]
but why did we just jump Oh dead chicken
oh okay
no what's this okay as the fear of mice
mass associated with the smell of the
dead spreads hygiene makes great
advances along with the development of
towns of villages rudimentary sewers
start to appear and most villagers have
saunas public baths accessible to all on
a daily basis but everyone washes their
hands before each meal and sip can be
found in even the most modest buildings
good god I've gotta keep clean I guess
especially when the plague is about
they've done such a good job of just
selling the whole concept of the plague
in just the way that these this little
town is built the level design of it all
it's just so higgledy-piggledy good I am
NOT a freaking clue where I am I think I
think I've been here before and it's
just a mess
I guess that's how things were back then
this is the way I came right yes okay
okay
what what have I missed
Oh apparently there was a hole in the
wall with the chickens thanks for
letting me know Dustin where's that
chicken there's two chickens
past these
the village is contaminated that's why
everyone fighting
no wait is more things happening Oh
[Applause]
not
[Applause]
oh my god well I'd be done
you're the rest of them no wait we're
just looking for someone and you found
him it's your dumb musics what brought
them out huh
music dirty vermin that invaded our
church that filled with the dark our
children in their beds and gave them the
black thing but now you found Conrad
Martha this is the last village you'll
infect what the hell what they saying
I'm so confused what do they think we
are what what what oh all is quiet
or just that nice
you can come
let's go guys
they blame witches all my god witches oh
that's freaking cool
aye sir I used to do a lot on which is
when I was back in school but okay yeah
right this
I did my GCSE drama you have to find the
way out of it let's push it
we need to turn it around guys come why
is this so awkward come on we need no no
okay I'm trying to go backwards on town
at the same time it's not really working
turn please
backwards in that way come on
turn please oh my god why is this so
difficult
turn it please Jesus Christ she's not
turning it at all nope not now she is
but the wrong freaking way
my widens control so hard to learn right
come on there we go there we go there we
go there we go I guess they've tried to
keep it realistic it's weird because
it's like it goes with the oh yeah that
should that should be enough we should
we should be able to use this yes
I feel like this should be using my
rocks more because they're everywhere
but yesterday maybe not I was not on oh
here we go
[Music]
it's them let me hold catchy I'm gonna
push from this place
don't know if anyone actually here it is
oh gosh I'm stuck
yeah come I'll get you up great
mmm-hmm Michael you've never parallel
parked a box like come on although I am
basically a superhero yes oh oh you
little tattletale oh come on let me go
oh yeah Oh goals Oh scheisse
what what did he find oh that
we make a good team
oh so now up
the two of you surrounded the whole area
get out of here oh sure I find when his
kid died we have to burn things
oh how do I cancel shibez Oh bowls how
do I change it again dude just come
Coop's I don't know how to cancel it
after I started it because I was
pressing the sling one instead of the
rock
yep yep yep yep yep come on Pete
good boy
gibbehh
okay sleaze gettin that so what we will
do now is I guess how do I
put it put it in here and the hell was
that noise
perfect
great I am blue Emma let's get down
[Music]
really
Jesus Christ like one - hide run high
throw pot get it boy
be pretty
yes I totally know this up the chimney
go up the chimney dude what do we
actually do oh can I get in
oh I know no I don't know
wait I've got a change to my mop now I
know no I don't what do I do
oh did you get gotcha
I'm just like throw rocks of things
oh good here we go here we go
okay let's try again smells like running
[Laughter]
come on you go don't you play with my
emotions like this oh come on Hugo let's
go
Oh his migraines
he's gonna be like side up is gonna
explode thank you
oh my god a nice person ouu the best
oh she's inflected
I mean I'm grateful but at the same time
it's like they never come looking for
you here you're soaking there are
clothes you can change into upstairs oh
my god Michael Atomics like imagine
being the boy you've opened the door and
your sisters just running to the edges
come on open the door
wait take this alone oh my god and then
you're like I got it that she's just
like anyway um so we're not we're in a
plague Christmas house right now which
probably means that we're sick but I am
still really grateful to her because I
mean like we would be dead if it wasn't
haha my guest the chest is upstairs this
is a pretty pretty person is that you
when you were younger is that your
daughter what was the tale here
that's better what about you mommy's not
yet she told us to find the rent you
assume he's got point to do what she
told us and that's it you go wait
hmm
they feature good they belong to my
grandchildren
oh my my name is Clara this family's
here I mean this is sugar say thank you
sugar
thank you thank you what is happening
here the plague so many people are dead
and those still alive but where are your
parents at home they're working for us
we're looking for a doctor
the winch's he was a play here perhaps
and a man did come and help at the
hospice early on the monks might be able
to tell you more but what they haven't
been seen recently no one goes near the
church anymore
I see you have a sleep
but it will be no use to you in that
state go to the backyard you'll find
some new strips of leather there and
you'd feel free to use the workshop in
the next room for your repairs she's so
nice
feel free to use the tools by the
workshop oh you just don't trust her
maybe that's cuz everyone in this town
was this you just trying to kill me so
you know
there it is leather right let's get to
work
and more leather arose was that it was
over
nope that's it okay
come on keep calm and concentrate
it's much better hitting enemies in the
head kills them instantly
[Music]
[Music]
okay cool so I can level stuff up right
I must go and thank you
ah so it's a lot better
Thank You Chloe thanks for everything
odds are you're doing that let it down
but you're stupider what time not do
that don't shout children mommy you'll
never see her again
oh yeah
they were killed at the house both of
them so shut up how do they not hear
them okay I'm not a little boy I cannot
get you that
[Music]
you go like a little nuisance you're
gonna cause a riffraff
I promised mom I'd look after you
of those where we go now there we go
I should
oh god is dead good Oh Hugo are you not
scared boy
[ __ ] yeah while you did though
it's okay you did it for your brother
it's okay
we're just waiting for your rules
excuse me it's gotta be somewhere - here
oh I see I see that Thanks
I know
I thought it was you I don't think I
have enough strokes for this
Oh some works on the ground then I know
what it feels like to lose someone I
love I don't boast both okay was that
that man oh yeah I forgot they think I'm
a witch oh wow Jesus Christ okay where's
the places to pick up maybe somewhere
around here right the pickup oh no no I
can pick up there
hello Oh God I'm running
yes your son whoa die you did he hit
dead imagine that did enough against a
fully armored dude you know big-ass
weapon and you win with a rock let me
see you are walk superhero yeah I know I
can't but I was looking after you though
oh okay it's okay he's not scared
frisket
we scare them we can't just stay here in
a cute embrace
hey young king kid
that's true I could have just grabbed
the high hammer from the boys hand
hey Mrs T lion thank you for hosting
appreciate retribution
it's Chapter three I guess not he trusts
us because before he was like mommy can
help us mommy can save us and now he's
seen that I can he's like okay yeah
candles to show you oh you put them down
and you if you want to you make it right
thank you
you think it else used to get a mom
watch over them
it's funny the sound here there's an
echo hello Hugo
there might be people here oh oh yeah
what did I just pick up oh I don't know
oh it was something for my upgrades cool
yeah I should read keep lookout first
about that what's it for pre mom and dad
made from some materials is Nexus
service prayer guides they're extremely
widespread and self-assessment into the
inescapable role of religion in society
religion promises believers that their
souls were saved provides hospitals with
furniture and divides the year with
llamas in the shape of pageantry and
celebrations the church also hunts
heretics condemns the profane and in
more serious cases excommunicates them
depriving them of the right to faith and
isolating them from the community
oh we got some alcohol
I guess I see strop grades though again
imagine she's gonna be sitting on that
okay
forgive me for beautiful I love just
committed Monsieur you're already
squeezing me sorry
you had no choice maybe you did with the
first one maybe I could have just ran
away from him but with the other one you
definitely didn't look with you he was
gonna kill you can I get out here a
barricade why to stop someone from
getting in or out
somehow watching
uh-huh come on get up there it won't you
go trust me wait it's important we
should come and talk to him so he
doesn't need us he's got a bad back it
seems it has to be Oh they've broken
everything what's going on here perhaps
they're building bigger beds I don't
think that's it
definitely not miss this there's some
fabric for an upgrade still there what
do we need to upgrade stuff
a lot
much more than what I got by now that's
for sure
hey I ate my elbow that's that's an
interesting name to say out loud
and hey symbols that I am too stupid to
understand but thank you for watching
a skin Tatar fragrance Oh
how are you so charismatic Yasmine put
them in the water to purify themselves
mother used to do the same I think
that's a matter of opinion so I will
just say thank you it's what some people
find charismatic others find extremely
annoying fabric
[Music]
oh here we go fight let's go and find
father he seems nice enough
no this is real cute this is like
bordering on God of War obviously
because you've got a boy in you can I
take care of him but also just the
interactions and how it's kind of
slowing the pace down and I like that I
like the fact that it's still quite a
dark intense and a little bit spooky
game but they're not just making you run
around up see you everywhere we can have
these moments where we just enjoying
things and are allowed to become
immersed in what the game actually is
which is being back in medieval times
but with the plague I personally have
not experienced that so it's nice to and
I didn't have to do that can I start on
that beautiful to ponder moment anyway
I've got enough stones maybe that's why
it's gone so I'll just go through here
quickly look around make sure I haven't
missed anything
oh I'm stuffy asleep how am i doing for
materials I'm just waiting to earth
collected loads I love this little
flower on my hair I feel fabulous
father
you again I told you to leave moment
just you have no idea leave while you
still can
someone has to help us do it for him at
least
[Music]
the robber Tyrone go to bomb his
children we are looking for Laurentiis
the doctor do you know him yes yes I
know him and I know he used to look
after your family
I am father Thomas your presence here is
not a good sign
new musician they came and they I can
imagine but what is happening here is
far worse you must leave immediately or
you will die
father the villagers wanted to kill us
the church
we're an exit through the crypt of the
three Saints she may not be too late
I shall try to put you on the path
dilaurentises farm but after that may
God watch over you
all Sims coming for the moment
to stay the night
father
why have their crosses on the village
doors is it really the plate it started
with bytes during the night vampire
sickness spread first families then to
everyone
started dying oh cool and when we
finally found out where he came from
it was already too late frats where did
it come from
we're nearly there hey brother Mariela
should be here we are the last two
remaining
he's not gonna be here as he's gonna be
dead
brother Moret
stay here
present Marez
brother
No
what is the matter
further
[Music]
come back come back father come to the
light come to the light
oh my gosh there
yeahlet's is dropping from the wall it's
ridiculous but it's so funny oh my god
wonder if like they meant to have this
many or if it was just like a bug or
something they're like yeah sure
dang a bit laggy sorry it's going a
little bit like me I guess because of
all the all the rats wait my best to
them also
who find something come on I'll help you
uh-oh we can't pick that one up now yeah
we got it we got it we've got it
yeah like so imagine they were just like
oh yeah we'll just have a real normal
amount and then we something happen and
they're just like you know what the game
still runs let's just have crazy amounts
the priests spoke of a way out the Crypt
[Music]
there are no sticks around here for me
to get some ah yes
Oh nope that's not stick yes
where the bloody hell sticks ma'am I
mean I can see them they're everywhere
let me pick one out okay oh okay
right you come here boy you can come
down oh yeah you could just come to me
or whatever
stay here I'll be quick okay thank you
for the little tip game
try not to look we can't do anything for
them now it's alright you can come you
go through the cracks no
yeah
[Music]
okay what can I do from up here then
right we'll pass at the same time it's
not just gonna be swinging for a charity
yeah I guess hey skin star life it's
good helps your life is everyone excited
for the EP release by the way
nice get more pocket not bad not bad at
all
rats
spoke to scene sizes ah bait no no no
I'm not sure just like
they're insane let's get started with a
catalyst
EP is like a demo album so it's it's not
quite an album it's not a single either
let's be careful Oh God
okay so yeah okay so if you see some
meat it's all right yes yeah good boy
okay yes you just meet there
come on Hugo oh yes stay where you are
the ground is rotten we'll find a way
you don't worry as long as you have the
torch you'll be safe we'll move together
that's why the lights coming through the
grating Milotic oh okay yeah sounds good
it's a good idea she is she is a wise
wise woman hurt oh my god oh my gosh
thank you behind you
that's the only way I can see go through
there and I'll meet you on the other
side are you sure just stop if you see
rats
I'll be with you very quickly all right
please hurry
Oh
reckon I go though
I'll do that yes good here
it's annoying they keep designing it so
I can't takes it'll take the light with
me okay where are you
[Music]
I don't know where to go
ah
okay I don't like this means they can
feel like something terrible is about to
happen but he can't die
he's like the whole point of the game so
nothing is gonna die oh I just realized
were in the toilet perfect
this hole oh okay I didn't know realized
that it was gonna just go out like that
let's try this again we have a time
limit
dude we didn't even get notified that it
was about to go out really it was just
like oh yeah it's about to go out and
then Sony's just out got like a second
snow is maybe
by rats
I know it was a bit mom I'm just silly
how soon realize the audio for it
crackling up is not very high
yeah good
we're going to get you down from that
good boy calm down
she's fine you're fine stick sugar I
have to get him down here
Oh buy anything so I need to go through
these rats I guess you're gonna run
oh you can't run with it grandma headed
towards
that's not justice
ah here we go okay
wait
can we got ourselves another one bad
um this is sticks right here oh yeah
it's fine
hmm okay we're gonna have to go to that
one don't get it let's leave
yep oh yeah
Oh perfect thank you beautiful oh she
said the same thing as least isn't that
immersion at its best
there we go nice great
I shouldn't have left you alone it's too
risky that's alright I'm gonna go up
there just to see if if anything you
might want to grab they came from the
sewers I'm imagining Mike hope I get
what you mean they're pretty crazy it's
like ah which is assault or something I
don't know
it has been a century since the last
Great Crusade and the church faces new
perils disease famine war calamities
push away push humanity toward faith
this need for spirituality combined with
the many human losses forces the clergy
to train many priests in haste but some
of the people will nevertheless seek
answers in paganism supposition and
dissenting orders
[Music]
nice
yeah lovely went up here
all right
Oh witches aren't involved oh but
they've been blamed okay fair enough
but this is like a crazy amount of rat
so I'm just wondering how much is this
is gonna be historically accurate or not
I don't think we have enough stick to
get us through that
Oh
again
thank you we can get out of here now yes
oh wait let me pick everything up first
anything else nope ooh so you can either
upgrade our pouch which is a pocket of
wrestling for a larger piece of leather
and witcher projectiles can be inserted
more easily or ammunition bag such as
poke the fabric about animation bags and
leather increasing its carrying capacity
high mmm so that's accuracy time and
that's ammunition I guess I munition
would help this should make things a
little easier
rats were not being killed there were
eating corpses was gave them food - this
is dramatized but imagine the catacombs
of Paris back then how oh yes
first I can I was like wait you mean
show me rats for killing people but then
I realize you you said eating corpses
says that they were already dead that
make sense yes I I can't imagine it was
nice oh but this is crazy
okay not wasting any time
[Music]
okay I don't want it to trip on me
rats plague nest
it's burning my throat
let's go
Oh back into the forest we did it we did
it we did it
I don't want that to be dead you go
[Music]
The Apprentice hey Daniel thank you I'm
glad you think it's nice live stream
I don't think they were sewers in the
Middle Ages people just dump stuff into
the rivers juice no but there were like
an underground civilization no it's too
dangerous
maybe I don't know Hugo I'm stuck we'll
be safe with Laurentiis come on yes so
you can still go I think anyway um into
the underground parts of Edinburgh
because there were some cities where
literally it was like a whole nother
world and underneath the city I hope so
okay hold up guys
you know me the woman with the world's
smallest bladder so I'm gonna going to
the toilet
[Music]
but before I go I'm just gonna tell you
again that my friend is streaming D in D
for mental health so if you want to go
and check that out maybe give a little
donation
cuz it's Mental Health Awareness Week I
don't know if you knew but it is then
feel free to check that out
I'll leave a little link in here now in
the chat for you guys but yes I shall be
right back don't go anywhere
I'm gonna be back I'll just leave it on
the screen why not
you
you
you
[Music]
hello I'm back
how are you should I make no I'm not
doing that sorry I just went no like
right hey hey I hate whisperers in
general I just hate the sound of people
whispering it's really freaks me out
I'm back hi um how often do you go Pete
yes sushi more like yes usually about
once an hour maybe although I was I
think I've been streaming for two hours
so I guess maybe once in the two hours I
don't I just drink a lot
okay
hey Kaley and I get how people like
whispers so much like how I know I just
I just say I try and explain to people
who don't get it and I'm just like I
just hate how when you whisper people
are like it's all like the mouth noises
is it I hate them it's just that like
that the tongue noise is like even me
doing it now I'm just like no please
stop oh okay
Michael peas ability okay that makes
feel better thanks I swear like I always
think my I mean I ever think everything
anyway but I always think and work they
must think that I'm just like trying to
waste time by going to the toilet all
the time but it's not I genuinely need
the toilet anyway let's get back to
playing the game shall we
yes I think that's a good idea
okay back up bring it back up oh my god
you're so right Maria that you the
eating s of our videos I cannot deal
because I hate the sound of people easy
as well so it's like two of my worst
things just whispering mouth noise
sounds and eating well I guess ya know
it's one thing it's just mouth noise
sounds I hate so eating sounds like and
there's some food channels like that do
like mukbangs and look bones and they
eat just like so sloppily and then I'm
like no no no no okay
Daniel says we all need the toilet well
you guys did you just I just gave you a
toilet right what were you doing you
wasted your time oh well we're gonna
carry on now okay I need a comfy a chair
and someone like donate me an actual
chair to sit on
that's like comfier than a wooden chair
it's fruity not comfy so I'm just saw my
legs right now anyway
by the way I was joking Oh buy myself a
chair eventually I just want to buy one
now because I don't get a move house
again at some point the Inquisition
thank you you're very observant oh boy
honey
the toilet is our best friend do I look
like a rat how should I know
but I say we'll never get rid of these
nests using stupid line whatever happens
we have to get out of here before the
Sun Goes Down they like the dog so back
to business
I will be back soon you have to be quite
me you I just don't see how I'm gonna
get around them if I do it there but I
guess I mean if you tell me to do that
then I will I did hear something over
there mmm I know you did come on then
nothing nothing here
movie maybe I got a third like over here
I just say that
he's already facing those I don't know
how that's gonna help us maybe I can use
my boss
[Music]
let me can come here please can you come
here over here
[Music]
something going on again let's go
overlooked yes good
I'll forego no are you serious
that's mine
okay let's try this again so I know I
just gotta do it twice and then he'll
come over and then I guess it was just a
bit too eager
probably yeah oh okay yes I think that
we can do this both with our rocks
what's all the racket running again
right let's go and see
so you can actually see us I don't don't
want him to understand
I found something this time thank you
bit me angry
well you succeeded oh how the blood I
just need him to go around the other
side of it I'm doing okay so I'm gonna
chuck it mm-hmm trigger twice and he'll
go over there if I go now you're gonna
see me
okay but if I throw it again he is gonna
go to the shops and then I can jump over
I guess someone's looking for trouble eh
happy to oblige
oh I thought you're gonna go over there
okay I don't know why I'm struggling so
much with this what is just try my
original attempt again first time was
already too much let's go
see that she's like Lukey once he sees
me as soon as we get out so the last
time I threw this three times by him he
didn't go to the shrubs but he started
to walk backwards gonna be sitting right
let's go and see let's get back just in
case we do you need to hop over
oh are you being sick I just want to
hide behind here
what the hell am i doing one and wait it
doesn't do anything if I do one awake
heal it she doesn't move
what the Frick he's moving
nothing
turn your ass around okay now we go I'm
too impatient for some scary milk
there's a bridge that leads to the farm
I am the Grand Inquisitor should just
tell us what he really wants from us
okay
so we go back this way you stay here
sound
I like to disk all these arrows that
tell you who you're about to UM who
you're about to kind of cross over there
so I don't have to worry about getting
them both because that would be annoying
second barricade
I know this isn't very where to go by so
shiny things
oh [ __ ] balls balls blue balls I just I
just wanted to shiny things
oh that was about ready good okay I'm
gonna try and take my time good more
stay calm and wait for me here right
come be careful
ah through the shrubs
don't move I'll be back very soon and I
mean I want to get this stuff
what's he doing this digging dick dick
dick dick dick dick dick dick dick dick
dick dick turn around
will he notice that the chest is open
is he that intelligent know him poofier
I'm not sacrificing my brother oh oh I
was talking to you for Theo I miss my
MoMA is fine I'll just wait again Jews
Instagram
yes I used Instagram Nick Oh Jack my ex
yeah come on ex everybody admin ex
follow me on Instagram
I do post on them more often than those
I used for a lot as well
yeah okay go go go go
what's down here oh it's just to help us
with him oh it's okay he can't see us
[ __ ] oh my god come on girl let's go
okay so noted they can see through the
wooden barricades but it's okay what we
use the pot and go away
I'm too big you'll have to trust me
it's okay you go
this is good as well because they're
doing a very simple action but you can
hear every time they look scooped and
then dumped so you know exactly when
they were turning around
doesn't mean I'm gonna be any better at
the game but it helps okay so I'm gonna
wait until he comes back and then goes
back again and then I'll chuck my old my
little stone and then I'll tell my
brother that it's time to go
what is that noise
dude go why aren't you going I had to do
it from here okay that's bad why
couldn't I have done it from over there
as well doesn't make any sense that was
a stupid you can only tell the boy to do
the action from a search area okay I
guess he has to be looking directly
yellos
that noise better go see what it was
nothing
yes
and I don't have a pot either oh I do
she don't use it
maybe
maybe I could just run now oh I I give
tit
I know
that's right that
okay it's okay
stay here and not to sound right Musti
what I just wanted to [ __ ] it up
I just wanted to stand up to get a
better view
[Music]
I'm not crazy I'm not being stealthy at
all look at me I'm just like yeah [ __ ]
it just go just do it just no way just
over there now do not stand up no stay
top wait for me here
let's go Bobby now
they plucked up the phone any person or
vehicle that wants to get through is to
be stopped and sir and what are we
looking for exactly
okay God wanted him alive very important
I was told Lord Nicholas has his orders
direct from the Grand Inquisitor himself
so keep your eyes peeled
- they'll see me if I let you just cross
through there because they're not
looking this way
the horses are maybe they'll spot us no
no okay
the horses are like hey they're over
there I don't know what the whole that's
not okay I'll shut up
courses are not ride oh thank you I
didn't see him I would have walked right
into his hands need to get a boat
you just gonna stand there
oh [ __ ] okay so next time I'm gonna go
around like this but I'm just I'm just
oh [ __ ] they lost me here suckers
careful who you lend try to stop me yeah
we are you know it
okay these work bunches are like say
brooms I guess that's safe I'm mission
bag pop it improves the students quit
making faster and more efficient yes
please oh I can't do that Oh fair enough
I can't do any of these oh no I feel
like I shouldn't be running
oh yeah what what is that you buy only
nothing for me you didn't do anything
it is special they're the ones who did
something if they catch us will they
hurt us they are not going to catch us
all right all right
nice horse noise Thank You officer no
Vito okay I feel I feel sleep safe here
am i right in thinking today yeah I know
he's running so I guess Hugo Hugo where
are you this is not the time for
hide-and-seek boy oh boy
the Inquisition is here Hugo do you want
them to take you away don't ever do that
again all right
hey piggies
which is he facing always facing
everything
we were okay I think
nice
okay free eggs
[ __ ] okay we are so lucky they did not
she decide they are
I did hear something over there are you
going good
oh I want to go back and get a part of
it so I can only hope one at a time
ate nuttin here he's a real boy
aatrox
this guy's just going around around
around speaking dizzy
I want to open that box and what the
loot oh okay let's try that again
nothing to report as I saw
I have been they both go towards it
there's any one guy I'll wait I'll wait
I'll be patient I'll wait if you feel
back around again
hey cansado you came back and I'm still
around yeah
welcome back okay not now not now I wish
to told you how like what the range was
of people who are about to hear this
quick quick yeah mush
but I'm mashing but a machine okay yeah
got smarter together but you will though
button yeah did you touch him because
when a rat bites you it poisons your
block you get boils all over and
everyone around you can get it and die
too that's why it's called the bite ah
see no vampires just rats whose crazy
hordes of rats
I need to do it double one so you over
there you hear
let's go
but I was sure
well it was nothing
when are they going to call us back to
camp she's very dark
this is this is tents guys I don't gotta
take Grady I can get killed I know
nobody got me killed a couple is life
but I can't help it I just want all the
gear I want the best gosh darn rock
throwing weapon ever hmm it's time this
run into these bushes
we're not run don't worry I already know
as soon as I stand up someone's gonna
see me okay here we go yet
time to perfect it yes
like can we walk through oh yeah we can
okay going yet I'm just so vain just so
vain just let them you know check in all
my different ways I can go around you
okay you put a muscle let's go
oh these are the little rap hits aren't
they where the rats come from what's
down there
I feel like I missed a whole slew of
things but I feel like I should be going
this way but I kind of want to look
Tupman though can't be bothered bigger
in this way
they can't see us anymore no they can't
for the time being
come on I'll help you alright
what's happening the rat plague again
can we stand up now are we gonna get
killed nope we can start uh-huh what a
triumph you'll be able to rest when we
get to Lorenzo suppose you have to tell
him about his old cloud like his mom
dead I like your mom did I don't know
what to do Hugo I can carry you that's
the best I can do come on
now
she's a good sister you just tired
nothing
yeah I guess she's got to feel a bit
bitter because he spent all of the time
with the mum and she didn't get to see
her mom but you can't blame him give it
up go faster sometimes it's fun too
you'll get better one day you better get
down sugar okay this swamp does not look
fun I don't believe it
look at all this Oh horses and cows oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god okay go go go
oh yeah cuz the soldiers were saying
it's nearly nightfall
[Music]
I'm gonna round in cycles on but
[Applause]
okay
I'll get you up right I really feel like
they should have cause then
hmm
this music is cool
haha oh wow I did not realize that was
all dead and the roach
Oh they've been slaughtered by the
Inquisition probably gone is sick
I guess they were infected
[Music]
okay
let's go just
I wish we could walk faster
this is not gonna be enough time ready
are you kidding me you can't work any
faster than me bull there must be some
stakes near and there is enough
no date they've been slaughtered by the
Inquisition probably be sick
okay oh okay I guess if we if we get
stick from here we can ignite it later
what the [ __ ] am i doing good let's just
run into the rats yeah sure why not
okay here we go no we're like 90
let's go just
get
oh it's right up here come on here we go
again
[Music]
oh cool so I'm gonna just push this baby
push
would help if I was better staring this
Megan why did you think you maybe to
contain the rats here
oh yeah maybe you have to just just a
little bit longer good
there we go
can we push it see these doors we did it
we made it Shaco Yelland what if it's
not the rent is did you think of that
is it Lauren teos cuz the music sounds
quite nice it's very a bard like C I
appreciate little details like that like
when you walk up to something because
you're interested and then the
characters actually understanding you've
walked up to it with purpose and they
even if it's just a little conversation
q Wow look at those pink okay um yeah no
I mean I'm really sorry
[Music]
hey horsey
no tonight to stay outside so did the
rats attack animals too
I guess they would do
it's locked you go you go in there and
open it with me quit it and be very
careful right good
oh thank you I'm just this is not really
the time you know please right go ahead
she's gonna end up with loads of flowers
on my hand
well how does my mouth flow yes it's not
good to be on yeah all right let's go
[Music]
what for Eagle
this is such a cute little mechanic oh
yeah we can collect flowers and not for
the puts them in our hair for us in
sweet it's alcohol from the students oh
it's good
hold on let me just do this for us if I
can Oh mmm yes
running and dodging makes less noise yes
pudding definitely
I'm gonna plump plump it stop the fire
another guy's done oh stop right there
he's contagious we lost everything there
was nothing I could do of course for him
and the even ancient evil courses
through your family's veins in its blood
[Music]
your mother and I attempted to slow its
progress but ever since the great break
the process has quickened
you must protect him Monsieur
continue your mother's work
but how my parents tried to know they're
both dead
leave me alone Oh No
threats are dangerous but disorganized
the Inquisition however they seek the
boy tirelessly we have to disappear
head to the shuttle don't brush look at
go to the bar you will finish the
Agnetha don't try to talk I will prove
myself I'm sorry about your parents but
you're not alone anymore we have to move
fast
you can help me make the Agnetha it will
protect us from the rats what a brave
boy okay come here
I don't want you to stay here yeah you
just yelled at him I don't think he's
gonna want to hold your hand anymore you
just wanted to get away so there's a
curse on the families what are we going
to do
good idea they're frightened of the
light the lunging
do it you have to put out the light
that's it
Hugo give me your hand very well but
stay close to me it's been a long trip
it's not saying close to me would I just
pick up
yeah
the abbreviation of Latin formula the
CETA in term meaning visit the interior
of the earth and by rectifying what you
find there you will discover the hidden
stone
this Maxim sums up alchemy alchemical
philosophy based on the study of the
fundamental nature of the elements that
surround us and how they are transformed
these initials are also another name for
itself uric acid used to modify the
substance mm-hmm
wait am i brother go you use me not in
that room
brother brother dearest
what
oh they've always swam out the front
door well that makes sense
I'm just running on the house clueless
brother they were
he's really annoying me
give me the silent treatment they've
come back they're everywhere
we have to reach the back of the barn
you can't leave without beautiful Howard
him to do it
Oh apparently me she is 15 he goes five
see that's why cuz someone already was
like oh yeah shouldn't shout at him ba
ba ba but she's young so oh no I don't
want to kill the piggy you know the
horse and definitely chicken I don't
want to kill things to go so innocent
that's it
[Music]
we have to make sure it stays I'll close
the door
so what do we do I don't want to jump
over that
do I close the door and you said you
closed it okay there's a ladder down the
side come on let's go
you go you go listen you can sulk if you
like with stay close
I'm still wearing the pretty flower you
gave me Hugo
the lights yes Hugo look away please why
I'll just do it please
[Music]
we have to get the rats away Hugo there
was no
I'm not idea this is where whatever say
about like the Evans otherwise way about
that's another word gosh that's grim
there anything for me to collects this
is more than just a doctor's lab my
Master's a great Alchemist your name is
a measurement I'm Lucas I would like to
show you something but it requires
alcohol and so forth there must be some
around here tell me when you found me um
right alcohol and something alcohol
salsa that's everything oh I hate ready
got them before the conversation I'm
dissolving the V agents oh it's it's
actually spin I'll graduate of time it
must be what they call an ethanol
levite extracting sick Latin
cool he's a wizard right now you have to
mix them do it slowly it's not dangerous
all right
I'd chemists can now cross the Ignite
for hold ivory
so this is it
nice detail Balaji
did I really just do alchemy yeah your
mixture is perfect like mother like
daughter
do you know what I'll show you how to
creat other projectiles this will be my
mom what oh yeah of course you will
thank you
I finished my mixes we have to go back
to Laurentiis meat yeah you should go
ahead
yes I want easel let's do it back throw
it on the elbows
please come on get up there
there's a lot of them vinci's I wouldn't
they come from this one here a second
ago were they I can't go maybe because I
will be looking at the course come on
leave me alone you go listen about
earlier I just wanted to tell you that
I'm probably not the right time
oh my gosh okay he's not alive in that
definitely not
[Music]
we ignite around
Oh plugin
oh yeah yeah you're a clever one
let's go Brown Van Van Van Ben
I don't think you kisses with caring has
in like laughing it's the way they're
like scuttling on top of each other like
crazy
[Music]
noise
The Raven spoils I think this is
probably where I'm gonna end it actually
guys will watch the little intro video
[Music]
Lucas
yes what does he have in his blood
there's an old story it tells of the
Prima macula the alchemist said was the
first corruption and that it silently
travels in the blood of certain families
but something happened the great break
and the macula a walk in Hugo's blood
but what will it do to him the macula
cares for neither good nor evil it
evolves with his holster the change
things the world you know who mother and
Laurentiis but trying to help your
brother but they failed no I think they
just ran out of time this is it that's
the positive outlook
you go wake up
come on we'll walk from here it'll warm
you up if you follow the aqueduct when
you should arrive at shuttle you don't
want before nightfall
what's that nice nothing it's just frogs
you go he seems well let's keep our
fingers crossed
I want to see the folks aren't you cold
the little yes Hugo doesn't seem to mind
he's keeping my cell phone yes but he's
too far for my liking there's a frog
you go
Hugo where are you going to go get back
here you go
in English you know where did you find
that listen Hugo put that down
it's not for children maybe we could use
that though I'm moving on man you guess
the plague or the rats or some more dead
things than thereby if it's not bad I
guess maybe dead soldiers if we just
found she'll be my guess
yeah
oh my god
[Music]
we can't carry on Alysia we have to
follow the aqueduct
I know if you go
you don't have a choice no this is
horrible
just keep moving Hugo come on she's
literally thinking that times while like
this went to the point where we had
world wars and people who were just
killed in troves like this and that kind
of still happens someplace
it's just unthinkable
hmm
the horse Lucas oh no it's full of rats
it's full of rats it's better fries yeah
I said it was gonna stop playing I'll
stop playing soon I'm just warning you I
will stop playing soon
yeah I know why don't we go now can we
turn around can we go a different way we
can go under here oh no this is fast
there too oh yeah there's okay
yeah
what a time to be five not a fun time to
be five definitely not a fun time wait
what the Frick just happened huh okay
what did I just see it's kind of looking
at the end I was looking at the chat so
I think I missed whatever happened there
Oh standing on brats okay
I thought mmm no cuz there was a prompt
that came up this so I don't see me as a
living but they said they weren't
soldiers so what the hell oh maybe it
was just that was Sammy a rat
oh god oh god oh god
iris right next to the light you should
have been out keep what is this what is
this fun I'm gonna literally hug the
light guys we need to hug the light the
light
[Music]
poke the light hug hug the lap we're
gonna hug and let house hunt the light
take those thanks super super super
super super close so you can die again
just stay really close
that's not gonna reach I want to count
so I don't know how to cancel so I don't
waste sir
No
they're just rocks could you lend a hand
yes of course what are we doing
Hugo no no no no no no minutes up yeah
don't do it
no what was - okay
oh I see what I have to do now right
okay so here we go
and then we can make that one come down
low enough all right
to ignite that's stuck it sticks I
thought I'd just be able to throw one of
my fire stones out of their parenting
it's too far away
oh yeah now he can good run bad I'll
come back they actually don't think that
okay let me skill part where I'm going
around we're going down there
tell me skills I've done you - thank you
[Music]
into the grass quickly
you mustn't see us Kamisha he'll enter
oh cool okay let's do this then
oh wait I don't wanna waste my good ones
doesn't matter you're gonna be eaten
[Music]
it's horrible but it worked
mmm
okay and I guess they're gonna be - yeah
distracted by him
[Music]
there are too many reps we're stuck
the dead guy was being eaten by by the
rats see underneath the rat oh now where
I can see light
how do I get that I
aha
kiyow kiyow kiyow kiyow kiyow
oh if only his Lanson woulda stayed lit
then i kept takin his bloody lantern
that would have been great so uh it's a
little loot upstairs right now
hey anwered the game has so many rats
because it's about the plague so it's
you know it's fitting the rats spread
the plague we should we go
the right spread to Prague
and then
no I don't have nothing to else
let's get stick it'd be great if like
the the other guy could grab a stick too
and I wasn't the only fire bearer but
I'll deal with it
can I stick it in these shrubs
oh god there's so much to think about
okay
remove it bit by bit and then I don't
have to get a headshot because I could
get the lantern either way headshot or
lantern I'm gonna oh I need to change my
weapon cuz I don't want to waste any of
my fire rocks multitasking it's hard
skill okay okay yeah I just wanna use a
normal rock
[Music]
help me push I'm coming for me / soda
none the wiser
nope yep yeah and now they're busy but
we'll still will salute anyway just in
case cuz you you know how much these
brats that killing me and I don't want
to take my chances where is the body
I see there's the body there you go who
wanted to see the bot again was that
officer Torito or Android 101 are you
guys there you go
he gets to the body and I are you happy
I might have a chance you've got
[Music]
I should have followed him okay I'm
gonna follow him when he comes back
then I can use his lights of protection
I know it's a it's a little bit
audacious I guess but we chose
why's he just did that I just put this
back and kill this dude
dude I got is freaking you saw that I
got oh okay
cuz it wasn't a lantern and it's made of
metal so it bounced off so I need to do
oh I don't even know if I can do a
headshot headshot because he's wearing
Troy wants more time if not then I'll
leave two hours ago
I'm getting hungry now I might have a
chance if I go alone
stand these rodents you've got nothing
better to do than muck around with a
cause okay time to go I will try again
next a lot of fun though I really
enjoying I really enjoying I'm really
enjoying this game so let me know if you
are yes let me know what you think of
this game and for you wanna see more of
it I'm really enjoying it so even if you
don't want this treatment I'll probably
be playing it more anyway but yeah thank
you for watching anyway and I'm gonna go
and make some dinner at home and yes
it's just burp internally that was where
don't like yeah yeah so thanks for
watching sooner route oh thanks watching
N word thank you Michael
tonic and Maria pizza and Catalan George
Percy I knew just comes already hello
goodbye but hopefully I'll be streaming
this again very soon bye licky goodbye
my remains and anyone else who is
watching but are not in the chat if
you're just lurking then
yeah thank you
goodbye I love you dare evening oh that
just one last time I just want to say
about the twitch stream that is
happening I think it's still happening
when it ones that finishing so there's a
twitch stream hosted by sleepiest yeah
and it finishes at 10 I believe so if
you're bored and you want something to
watch you can watch this Dungeons and
Dragons stream and it's there raising
money for mental health awareness so I
think that's really good so go tell
Millicent yes say hi all there jazz
[Music]
and yeah everyone's coming out of the
out of the shadows now so bye
Satya JIT by Foo fiea
by Dustin echoes by Chris Shepherd and
goodbye
anyway okay
[Music]